and I said to the Sailor broken cuz  nobody came to talk to me and where to  get off to get some more tanks on  another ship bc so he said get off he  said you look through the porthole so i  looked through the port on we were at  sea so I said well where are we going he  said well go to the France of course so  that was me on the invasion that's d to  we floated about on the sea with the  ship creaking and grambling over because  it was over Laden we got to Normandy on  gold beach on very early in the morning  four o'clock in the morning on d4 and we  took the first set of the first tank  went off it went down instead of going  in and stopping on the floor of the bit  on the beach there was a hole and it  went down turned upside down complete  with the men in it and disappeared and I  didn't like that I've tell you I felt  like being at home with mum  you